What do we do about computing statistics like those in an unsorted list.
Well, plan A, especially for mathematical-minded people, might be to sort the list first,
which as we say reduces the problem to one previously solved so that is safe.
We know how to sort. We can sort the list and then apply the ideas the we had just been talking about.
We're going to be talking more about sorting in a little while, but for now,
the important thing to know is that the running time of sorting is Î¸ (n log n) for a list of length n.
this is under the comparison model, but the important thing to make note of here is that
it's worse than just running through the list, right?
You have to run through the list repeatedly log n times essentially
and that may be overkill in some cases.
If you're interested in a very quick and possibly entertaining introduction to sorting,
I've got a music video on the topic called The Sorter,
which you can find on YouTube, we'll try to send the link.
Plan B is to try to extract the statistic that we're looking for
in effectively one scan through the data so Î˜(n)
and the time that it takes to zip through the list looking at the values
we should be able to get certainly the min and the max.
It turns out that we can actually get the median as well, which is really interesting result.
Let's start off with the very straightforward one.
The mean of a list with the average of a list this is how a statistician might write it.
Âľ or the mean is the sum over all the elements on the list from 0 to n-1
We look up the value, we sum them all together, and then we divide by the number of values.
It's just the definition of an average, and it's really straightforward to do that in Python as well.